ce soir nous partons dans le sud de la
saône-et-loire où l'ancien député gérard
voisin fait son retour eric oui l'ancien
parlementaire ump et candidat dissident
dans le canton de la chapelle de
guinchay où comme à mâcon à la campagne
électorale est marqué par les divisions
à droite c'est une nouvelle bataille
dans la guerre historique entre gérard
voisin et le maire de mâcon jean-patrick
courtois
reportage de stéphane robert et
gabrielle talon la victoire au bout du
chemin où la fin du parcours politique
gérard voisin joue gros sur cette
élection une nouvelle échéance
électorale sur fond de guerre tanase
féroce entre l'ancien député ump et
l'actuel maire ump de mâcon jean-patrick
courtois avec dans leur sillage une u10
équilibristes très souvent proches du
point de rupture
la candidature de gérard voisin n'a pas
été validé par les instances nationales
de l'ump
pire elles ont suspendu pour ne pas
avoir accepté de la retirer au profit
des candidats investis
l'ancien maire de charnay les mâcon loin
de se sentir des avoués maintien ne pas
avoir pris connaissance de ce courrier
recommandé daté du 4 mars dernier
plusieurs ump que moi c'est difficile de
trouver en mâconnais surtout encore
aujourd'hui quant à la suspension
j'annonce quand même que je n'ai
toujours pas cette fameuse lettre que
certaines presses et autres gens
considèrent que qui sont arrivés dans
dans certaines chaumières
vous l'avez pas je ne vais pas je ne
vais pas elle existe sûrement elle
existe sûrement puisqu'elle a été
annoncée en recommandé mais je ne l'est
pas malgré tout jean patrick courtois
connaît trop bien son adversaire et les
rouages de la politique pour ne pas
prendre en compte les dangers d'une
candidature dissidente dans cette terre
viticole poussant le sénateur maire de
mâcon pour la contrer a expédié en
première ligne le maire de chaintré
viticulteurs de profession estampillée à
lattes ump udi dans un contexte qu'ils
pensent favorable à une bascule jean
françois cognard ne mâche pas ses mots
il espère pourtant une entente dimanche
si les suffrages sont en faveur de cette
droite divisée j'ai un voisin c'est y
représente la défaite pour moi il
représente la défaite il était il était
battu aux législatives il était battu
chez lui
acharné en présentant une liste en étant
derrière unis ce qui était balayée
et il a même essayé de se présenter
contre le maire de mâcon enfin ainsi de
suite
il en veut il en veut à tout le monde il
veut et on se demande si son souhait
c'est pas de nous faire perdre plutôt
que lui de gagner il sait très bien
qu'il ne gagnera pas alors qu'on arrête
toute polémique je sais où j'en suis non
ma colistière le sait nos suppléants le
savent et nous n'accepterons à aucun
moment une affichette ou une écriture
sur le front que nous sommes des
diviseurs les diviseurs les diviseurs
ils sont ailleurs
ils sont ailleurs je le dis avec fermeté
et je le dirai quand avec encore plus de
fermeté
pour finir cette campagne de son côté la
gauche tient loin de cette division pour
ce binôme la problématique est ailleurs
s'appuyer sur le bilan et le programme
de la majorité départementale sortante
en gardant ses distances avec les
étiquettes politiques ne sommes pas
encarté nous n'avons pas de présentation
parti socialiste europe écologie etc
nous sommes des personnes de terrain
nous sommes des élus depuis quelques
années depuis quelques mandats nous
essayons de faire au mieux en fonction
de nos convictions personnelles qui
peuvent rejoindre des convictions de
partie on va pas le nier mais nous ne
cherchons pas à défendre a craint à tous
crins telle ou telle position d'un parti
si on en n'est pas d'accord même si
carole à la mercerie est encore
confrontés à des refus depuis quelques
semaines que cette candidate va au
contact des électeurs
elle l'a senti le message du front
national pacy mieux qu'auparavant dans
cette élection départementale
cette assistante de gestion de 42 ans
récemment victime d'un plan social
s'appuie sur les problématiques
nationales pour convaincre les déçus de
la gauche et de la droite le front
national a pas pour habitude de faire
des petites
les uns contre les autres nous on est
vraiment là pour pour les français pour
les représenter et puis pour faire
valoir leurs droits parce que c'est plus
en plus oublier les gens ont vraiment
envie que ça change en ont assez d'être
d'être abusés par tout un tas de
mensonges et promesses non tenues et je
pense qu'ils ont vraiment envie que ça
bouge
le fn qui espère profiter du contexte
local de division à droite pour jouer
dans ce canton un rôle d'arbitré et
poursuivre l'élan des dernières
municipales et à noter la présence d'un
dernier binôme alain gombert et vérune
15 urano pour le front de gauche
après la droite c'est la gauche de
côte-d'or qui était en meeting hier soir
et comme hier soir la salle devosge de
dijon était comble pour ce dernier
meeting de campagne
une réunion publique à laquelle a
participé le ministre du travail
françois rebsamen aux côtés du président
de la région françois patriat de la
députée qui aura besoin de nombreux
candidats
on notera aussi la présence de catherine
hervieu d'europe écologie les verts et
de claude pinon du mouvement des
progressistes eric comme chaque soir
qu'est ce que vous avez déniché sur les
réseaux sociaux avec va tout d'abord la
fermeture de la page facebook de john
ging ce conseiller municipal de chalon
qui avait partagé une photo d'un site
d'extrême droite montrant manuel valls
affublé d'une moustache d'hitler
il regrette et le député socialiste
christophe sirugue a accepté ses excuses
il écrit sur sa propre page facebook
monsieur guillon présenté ses excuses je
conviens de retirer la capture de son
poste pour apaiser un climat déjà
largement assez délétère sur facebook
encore un candidat de l'yonne s'en prend
à françois méro oui il s'agit de
sébastien dolo dit l'ex candidat udi sur
auxerre 4 qui ne décolère pas quand ils
voient que françois bayrou affirme qu'il
n'ya aucun accord entre le modem et la
gauche il faut dire que sur son canton
le patron du modem de l'yonne est
effectivement en binôme avec une
candidate divers gauche et puis sachez
que l'éclipsé de soleil a beaucoup
inspiré jusqu'au gouvernement qui a
twitté pour nous inviter à re voir
l'éclipsé lorsqu'on clique sur le lien
et bien voici une éclipse accéléré et de
mots qui apparaissent voter dimanche et
dimanche on ne votera pas seulement pour
les départementales à varennes-vauzelles
non dans la troisième ville de la nièvre
dix mille habitants les municipales ont
été annulés en raison d'un tract
litigieux il faut donc revoter l'an
dernier
rennes moselle avait été perdue par les
communistes au profit d' isabelle
bonicel cette année son équipe est de
nouveau en lice mais cette fois ci face
à une liste d'union de la gauche menée
par olivier sicot s i c ôté reportage
régis billon cécile claveau 30 mars 2014
un coup de tonnerre dans le landerneau
vos elia les communistes à la tête de la
cité cheminote depuis près de 70 ans
sont battu aux municipales par 26 voix
d'écart en faveur d' isabelle bonicel et
sa liste sans étiquette
même si ses adversaires la classe
toujours plus tôt à droite on n'est
absolument pas une liste de droite ont
émises de citoyens le citoyen qui ont
des sensibilités très diverses
on n'est pas du tout un divers droite on
n'est pas sans ton n'est pas un divers
gauche c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
coller français apprennent à utiliser le
mot sans étiquette veut dire quelque
chose d sans étiquette en face de partis
établis c'est le scénario qui s'annonce
donc dans cette municipale partielle
face à la maire sortante
une seule équipe symbolisant presse que
le retour de la gauche plurielle une
alliance europe ecologie les verts ps et
bien sûr ici le parti communiste en tête
de liste
non ce n'est pas une revanche pas du
tout mais c'est la volonté de refaire de
varennes-vauzelles qui a perdu ça
pendant dix mois une ville de progrès où
chacun à sa place une ville du bien être
une ville du du partage une ville qui
progresse une ville qui a une vision de
l'avenir
or
durant ces dix derniers mois nous avons
constaté un certain nombre de reculs sur
ces points-là dix mois l'ex maire ne
peut en effet que s'appuyer sur ce court
bilan que l'opposition de gauche
critique en ciblant surtout le volet
social et solidaire cette solidarité qui
était un peu le fer de lance de l'avivo
éoliennes à travers les associations à
travers l'implication dvd vaut aignan a
perdu a été gravement attaquer donc nous
on souhaite remettre ça au coeur de
notre ville le partage le vivre ensemble
dans la solidarité la juste solidarité
s'agit pas d'assistanat il s'agit il
s'agit pas de demander la charité et de
faire la charité mais il s'agit de de
faire en sorte que chaque veau et lien
chaque vous il est ce sont bien dans
leur ville en disant qu'on ne fait plus
de solidarité
c'est le meilleur moyen de dire vous
voyez ce sont des méchants on est sortis
de cet assistanat qui existait avant qui
était un assistanat électorale ça on a
mis une croix dessus c'est sûr mais
aujourd'hui chaque personne est prise en
compte comme acteur particulier chaque
personne est écoutée chaque personne ait
aidé et ça c'est la différence
chacun sa façon de voir l'aide aux
autres dimanche en plus des
départementales les volets lien
choisiront donc leur nouveau conseil
municipal
prime aux sortants ou le retour du pc
aux commandes de vos ailes après un an
d'internet
quoi qu'il en soit l'issue du scrutin
s'annonce serré
seule certitude la liste arrivée en tête
sera élu dès le premier tour
merci beaucoup eric et on vous donne
rendez vous dimanche pour notre soirée
électorale à partir de 19h et jusqu'à 23
heures à dimanche